well on the upside if you can't find
King Pun It's kind of like a cool badge
of honor to get suspended
but you usually go for people who get
suspended
um I don't really have a type it's more
of Just A vibe
so your Vibe is Aya then huh well
actually we just broke up
oh really
sucks sorry
are you over them depends Paige who's
asking not me I don't care
ouch
I care
I care I just was trying to be nice and
ask you questions so not that good at
that though well your questions are cute
so
do you remember in fifth grade when we
were partnered up to take care of that
egg together in Michigan's class
oh yeah I'm pretty sure I dropped mine
on the first day and begged my mom to
replace it for me
geez I totally forgot you're my partner
for that damn I was a shitty mom
well if it's any consolation I gave our
egg a bath and I boiled it to death so
guess I wasn't a perfect mom either
oh hi It's gotta be combined
yes I'm just not good at confrontation
clearly
kind of weird though with co-parents
I've never kissed before huh
yeah it's a little bit strange well
maybe we should try it
let me try
you can lean in now right now
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
that was awkward
oh [ __ ] they're leaving
[Applause]
[Music]
John I cannot believe that your stupid
Stakeout idea might have actually worked
but that was definitely Tim's car I
don't know who else drives a bright
green Challenger with a bumper sticker
that reads your mom calls me Daddy
[ __ ] Tim
uh hold on I have to take this
so do you think you cracked the case
yeah
I guess so
[Music]